the film has such a distinct sense of
tension and unlike Hitchcock who said
that you know we wanted the audience to
be aware of things that the characters
were not like in Saboteur as the Kato
sabotage in this film we were very much
with Emily's character as she's going
alongside Josh and and vinicio's
character and kind of immersed in this
world we're with her as she's finding
out about things is that how you saw the
is really the idea was really to embrace
that point of view all the way until it
switch brutally almost at the end of the
film and to I think that the idea of
create that and it was like that in the
screenplay to create right from the
start
violence that the audience would be in
contact with strong violence and knowing
that anything could happen when you
that's the way the first scene is
constructed it's just a big surprise and
violence erupt with very brittle brittle
away and after that you I think you have
the feeling of tension that anything can
happen and it allows it allows us to
play with the idea of waiting and
nothing happening you know and the
threat of that something could happen is
more powerful than anything else as as
the moving is going through there's a
lot of moment where we are tense I think
and in fact when you think about it
nothing is happening Emily the budgets
been made lately of the the strong
female characters action heroes and in
films were the lack thereof but I sort
of feel like your character Kate would
sort of roll her eyes at that I feel
like she would sort of say you know what
being fierce and being strong is just
one more weapon for her to to wield in a
way during this drug war is that correct
yes I mean I actually you know I I think
it's a good fight to have to talk about
these kind of female protagonists and
you know especially in a sort of
masculine action fueled world but um but
I actually always saw Kate as more
gender neutral and I also feel that
she's not necessarily a perfected
warrior and action heroine who can take
down any guy and as the perfect thing to
say at every given moment you know she's
a very real person and
she's a female cop in in a pretty
impossible situation in a situation
that's incoherent and at times
frightening to her even though she's
highly skilled and so she's quite a
multi-faceted character which is which
gets away from a lot of scripts that I
read where the woman is either tough or
she's the damsel in distress or she's
sexy or she's not or she's old or she's
young and this character has has an
ability to be many many different things
but if you I've heard alejandro your
character described as an avenging angel
I don't know if I would describe him as
that I almost would feel I almost feel
like he's a man who's trying to claw his
way back out of hell does that sound
like something that that approaches the
character in some way for you yeah I
guess like a like a polar bear would but
you know I think I think uh the
character when I read it was a very
compelling character because you
understood him and yet you were repelled
at the end by his actions you know so so
it's a type of character I think any
actor would love to jump at the after at
the task to build him and put him
together so you know I was very lucky
and glad to be part of it you know but
it's but he's got that thing that is
really interesting another aspect of the
performance that really struck me is
that you use your physicality in a way
with this role in a way I don't think
I've seen I mean certainly in che it's
there but maybe not since traffic you
really get in some of their suspects
faces like the way Ella Henry will just
use their space he'll move into their
space so often to intimidate them it's
really a remarkable bit of acting in a
way that I wasn't anticipating did you
see that
well maybe Denis had something to do
with that you know it pushing me to you
know get closer penetrate
Josh the I feel as if it's been a long
day Josh I feel like one of Matt's your
characters secret weapons is the sort of
American Atsushi and some sort of smart
aleck eNOS there's a lot going on there
but everything from the the flip-flops
that he's wearing to his sort of let it
roll attitude is a bit of an armor that
he has did you see it that way as well
yeah I don't I don't know an armor I
think it's more of he likes to keep
people off camber you know he likes to
keep everybody guessing and the more
comfortable he is I think other than
Alejandro everybody else starts to feel
like obviously something's going to
happen and it's probably not going to be
good and it keeps people sharp you know
I mean he's using her in her character
obviously but I think it's kind of like
Denis in a way keeps laying down crumbs
and even though he looks kind of
smart-aleck he and he has that
shit-eating grin on his face there's
something that is unnerving and
intriguing about it at the same time I
think I mean that's what I got when I
wasn't the intention but that's what I
got when I saw the movie which I heard
is pretty good it's very good as a
viewer doll so it keeps you off-guard
also but it makes you feel as if that's
kind of keeping him sane to Matt in the
midst of all this that sort of
intellectual distance is keeping Matt
sort of on the from-from going all the
way the edge right yeah I know I always
saw you know we've talked about this
more now than ever but I always saw his
personal life being so separate from his
professional life that he was able to be
these two characters you know I always
saw him as a great family man and a
great husband and running around with
his kids in the backyard but he doesn't
bring that side of himself into this and
remember hearing about the Ice Man once
you know the famous I don't know if it
was a serial killer or whatever but that
you know he did these things with his
kids and he put toys together Nico and
kills him buddy I mean he come back and
finished Christmas and he had kept it so
separately that when you look at the
the interviews with these guys it's kind
of amazing I don't know if it's a
sickness or if it's just the ability to
categorize you know partly I'm foreign
mentalize yeah so yeah with that with
taking the sickness out of it that's how
I always saw this guy you know I have a
professional thing that I have to
accomplish and then I have this personal
thing that has nothing to do with
anybody Roger I think I probably speak
for everyone in the theater here when I
say I wish I had every frame of every
film you ever shot on my wall as art
just I didn't season
what challenges were there in this film
and I'm thinking of two scenes in
particular one is the scene in the caves
at the end through the night vision and
through with it with the different
varying lights and also though the scene
with with Jon Bernthal and Emilie where
it's a love scene slash fight scene
there's an intimacy to both of those
moments that I feel like probably
presented unique challenges am i correct
yeah but no more than anything really I
mean sometimes that no everything has
its own challenges you know sometimes
the simplest little close-up is just as
difficult I'm in a challenge of any film
photography of any film this is
sustaining the look and the atmosphere
and not breaking out of that so if you
go into you know I'm going to the night
scene and going down to the tunnel we
discuss that at length because the
normally you would go into you scene
like that and you would look at active
shots of what's happening but in that
case they're wearing these night-vision
systems because it's so dark they can't
see well if you do a Hollywood kind of
moonlight look then it doesn't make any
sense so we took that kind of
conversation and and and also the over
overall approach to the film was this
kind of personal perspective we were
with Emily with Benicio you know so we
took that to say well we'll we'll do
this whole night sequence from the
perspective of the through the night
vision system so you know you take that
and kind of use it to your advantage in
a way you know you both have you and you
both have
background in documentaries I'm curious
about if that informs some of the things
in this film in terms of the visual look
of it the the documentary sort of feel
or especially sort of the bigger action
scenes or the or the scenes of more
mayhem did the documentary feel come
into it at all from my point of view I
should say coming from there it's just
that there's a will to be as accurate as
possible I mean I wanted from like
everything involving military behaviors
our vocabulary or the way they were
ending weapons around it was very
important for me that it would be as
real as possible
there was same thing with the Mexican
culture it was something that so from
there there's a and the from the start I
think Roger and I agree right from the
start that it would be a naturalism the
light would be very naturalistic will
embrace the brutality of that Sun and
not try to fight it but embrace it and
so yeah I think that there's a other
organizer that in addition we want it to
be as authentic as possible so the more
it would feel authentic the more know
you will feel powerful like I was and
he's carry in the same time yeah
speaking of authenticity and while you
trained did you train I read with with
SWAT teams and with some some either ATF
or FBI agents right in that area talk to
me about anything trenchant that they
may have given you in terms of that the
help of character that yes I did weapons
training and you know tactical training
with local FBI and DEA guys
predominately for that initial SWAT team
assault that you see at the beginning of
the film which was the first thing I
actually shot and there were also a
couple of ex-navy seals there and there
so there are different law enforcement
departments teaching me how did how to
do it and they'd all sort of squabble
about what the best way of doing a sort
of SWAT assault was but
but I I got there in the end you know we
made a decision but um yeah was it was
incredibly helpful actually to get into
the mindset of the character because you
can see how meticulously planned that is
just how efficient they are these FBI
SWAT teams as they go through a house
and and when I spoke to about four women
in the FBI you know to get a more
internal sense of the part I think none
of I think maybe one of them had had to
fire her gun
everything is so meticulously
strategically planned that it's rare
that a gun goes off and so they all said
it's disconcerting because you you get
nervous because as you go through that
door you never know they'll always be
the risk but they've been monitoring and
surveying this house for so long they
know exactly where everyone sits where
they hang out what rooms all of that it
was just very interesting to understand
the mindset of
of how how law abiding and also how how
meticulous they are and therefore
understanding why she's completely
thrown by being in a world where people
just spray bullets everywhere as soon as
she starts working in this makeshift
task force